Insidious is known for creeping out its audience with horrors, hiding in plain sight,
whether it be this creepy face on the bathroom mirror in the opening credits,
or the ghost of this boy blending into the laundry room as
Renai cleans up around the new house.
But there are also clues about the film's ending, connections to other
horror films by director James Wan and Blumhouse Easter eggs.
To learn why Specs uses raw steak to ice his head instead of an ice pack,
and other Insidious secrets.
Stick around to the end of the this video.
♪ Metal Music ♪
There are some horror movie details that are beyond our perception,
beyond our understanding from the physical world.
But there is another plane of existence, an infinite realm, where these
details are collected and analyzed by a mysterious entity with a goatee.
Welcome to Things You Missed.
Director James Wan is most known for his work in the horror genre.
Saw, Dead Silence, The Conjuring films, Malignant. I have been covering all of his horror
films here on Things You Missed, but there is one that I've been saving
until now.
In this episode, I'll be covering Stygian.
Just kidding.
That's not available.
So instead, we'll be stepping into the world of the Further to analyze his
2010 film, Insidious.
-[Elise] There are other entities who are malevolent and have a more insidious agenda.
This was a formative movie for my taste in the supernatural genre.
It was the third team up between Juan and screenwriter Leigh Whannell, and the
second film where Whannell would also play a substantial character in the movie.
These two love to hide Easter eggs for the fans, but before we get
into those, let's go back to the beginning to look at a few other
Things You Might Have Missed.
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
The opening credits are a clue about the midpoint twist.
At first, Insidious appears to be another haunted house or poltergeist type
film. But when Elise Rainier is introduced, we learn the reason behind the
appearance of these ghosts.
They're trying to possess Dalton because he's left his physical body vacant
during astral projection.
The opening title sequence shows the ethereal spirits of the text floating
up and disappearing.
When I covered Malignant, I also pointed out how the way the credits are
animated ties into a plot twist.
Elise refers to the out of body experiences that Dalton has as astral
projection, but the word astral has two meanings.
It's used to refer to something like the Further, which is on another plane
of existence, but it's also used to refer to something related to the stars.
When the term was first coined in the 1600s, they were basically one
and the same
because space travel was as an obscure of a concept, as traveling to another
dimension is for us today.
There are a bunch of references to space travel before we learn about astral projection in Insidious.
Dalton sleeps under a solar system mobile,
he draws pictures of himself flying up into space, he a solar system model on
his dresser, and he has an alien poster in his room that says,
music, from beyond your little world.
And in his brother's room, there's a whiteboard that says he has a science
project to due on the solar system.
I have no idea how he's able to reach that whiteboard, but it's a nice idea nonetheless.
Also, when Josh Lambert goes into the Further, you can spot a
man reading a newspaper which says something about Starline.
It's very difficult to make out.
There are also other instances of foreshadowing right from the very beginning.
When we first meet Dalton, he comes downstairs because he doesn't
like his room.
This is probably because he's seen the Red Face Demon or one of the other
spirits there, and it frightened him.
His mom, Renai, is flipping through a photo album, and he asked to see a
picture of his dad as a kid, but they don't have any.
This is teased again with this line from Josh's mom,
-[Lorraine] I can't believe you got Josh to hold still for a photo.
This is all because Josh has a subconscious fear of being photographed due
to his experience with the Bride in Black appearing behind him in photos as a kid.
Which Elise had to hypnotize him into forgetting about.
-[Elise] I advised Lorraine to hide them, to stop taking your picture,
-[Elise] to just let you forget.
However, I do think Lorraine's line is a little ridiculous.
It's not like Josh hasn't been in wedding photos.
There is a nice touch near the end, however, when Josh first enters the Further.
He's guided by a younger version of himself.
But because he has no photos from his childhood, he doesn't recognize
himself and momentarily thinks that it's Dalton.
At first, Josh doesn't even believe Elise about the whole astral projection theory.
It's not until he realizes that Dalton's drawings match up with what
she's saying that he becomes convinced.
We can see these drawings way back at the beginning, including Dalton
watching himself sleep, a series of red doors which serve as portals in the
Further, and even the Red Face Demon itself.
And speaking of red doors, they seem to play a significant part in the way
the film is shot.
The camera is constantly traveling through open doors or looking through
open doors in the real world.
I believe this is to highlight the difference between the real world and the Further.
The real world is bright and open and while this film doesn't have
a very vibrant color palette par for the course for late-2000s to
early-2010s PG-13 horror, the scenes in the real world feel more colorful
when compared to the literal monotony of the scenes in the Further which are
blue or red.
I feel like we can come up with a better name for this look than Twilightcore.
It's not just the look of these films that's iconic, though.
It's also the sound which plays a part in delivering some incredible jump scares.
Part of what makes the jump so effective in this movie is that
Leigh Whannell avoided writing any false jump scares.
There are no loud noises to accompany moments when it's just the cat or just
some kids playing a prank.
Composer Joseph Bishara created a lot of stingers that sound like someone
banging on a piano.
-[Renai] Dalton...
And this feels significant because Renai is a pianist who writes songs for
her husband.
The same instrument is used for Renai to express her love and the evil
nature of the ghosts around her.
James Wan is really good at finding creative ways to illustrate the whole
compare and contrast thing between the two worlds.
For example, the movie begins when we transition from the opening credits to
a shot of Renai laying in bed, where we fade from black and white into color.
It foreshadows the ending where Dalton makes it back to his body, and
we fade from the aesthetic of the further back to the colors of the real world.
Josh is a history teacher.
There's just something interesting about a history teacher who doesn't
remember his own past.
Speaking of which, there are a ton of Easter eggs in his classroom.
The first time we visit it, there's a list of students who have detention on
the chalkboard.
The first is Joe Hui, the craft service provider listed in the movie's credits.
Heather Mitchell was a set dresser, Lisa Cabello was a craft services
production assistant, and Kaylee Fisher was another set dresser.
James Wan, the director, apparently has double detention.
Yesim Osman was the head of the hair department and Leslie Borchard was a hairstylist.
Underneath that, there's a sketch of Billy the puppet from the
Saw movies.
Billy used to have a little cameo in every James Wan movie, and at the time
of writing, this Insidious Easter egg would be the last example.
However, I'm sure he'll appear again in the future, and he has shown up in a
couple of Leigh Whannell directed films.
But this appearance on the chalkboard is the most significant one of all.
Insidious technically first played in 2010, but it got its wide release in 2011,
a year after Saw VII, which was dubbed The Final Chapter.
So the Saw series was considered to be over by the time the Insidious
franchise began.
Underneath the chalkboard drawing, you'll notice the number eight, which at
the time was our only clue about a possible revival and 8th movie in the Saw
franchise. We would eventually get that movie with Jigsaw in 2017.
On another day, there's another scene of Josh staying back in the classroom,
and there are even more crew reference Easter eggs.
That day's round of detentions includes Rick Osako, who's the unit production manager,
Jeanette Brill, the line producer Jen Spencer, which is pretty close
to Jennifer Spence, the art director, Kate Mallor, a set dresser,
and Renetta Amador, the script supervisor.
There's one other sort of crew reference connection Leigh Winnell's wife,
Corbett Tuck has two roles in the film.
She's one of the nurses and doll girl number two in the Further.
The Billy the puppet drawing on the chalkboard was not the only connection
to James Wan.
Insidious also helped set the stage for one of his future franchises.
(Impact)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
In my various Things You Missed videos on the horror films of James Wan,
there have been a number of recurring elements that I've identified that
make Wan an auteur, or a director with a distinctive approach, making him
recognizable as the author of the movie.
For example, the film begins with the Labbert family moving in, and they end
up moving again before it's all said and done.
Dead Silence and The Conjuring both feature protagonists who move to a new house.
I've also talked about several of those films that feature spiraling
camera movements like Saw, Dead Silence and Malignant.
Insidious features something similar when Renai looks up at the noise coming
from the baby's room.
The film also begins with a shot that inverts 180 degrees, which could be
used to signify the change from the real world to the Further.
The Conjuring would do something similar when its protagonist,
Lorraine Warren, walks to and from the basement housing the witch.
She's essentially going from a normal place to an evil one.
In fact, I think James Wan originally wanted to make the conjuring instead
of Insidious.
The rules of this world are pretty similar to The Conjuring, and the
grandmother is even named Lorraine, and she's revealed to also have some
abilities as a traveler.
I almost wonder if he wanted to make The Conjuring but couldn't get the
rights until after making Insidious.
This idea is further backed up by The Conjuring Two, which features an
astral projection scene in the opening, very similar to the Further.
Personally, I prefer Insidious.
The main difference seems to be that the Insidious lore is made up with its
villains being based on creepy, uncanny valley ideas that James and Leigh had
been saving up, whereas The Conjuring tends to base its lore on religious
stuff in urban legends.
There is one aspect of The Conjuring I like better though, I think it does a
better job of fleshing out the backstories of the ghosts.
Another common element in James Wan films is puppets or dolls.
Of course, there's the previously mentioned puppet from Saw.
Dead Silence is all about puppets, and The Conjuring introduces the doll
Annabelle, who is also briefly in The Conjuring Two and Aquaman.
In Insidious, there's a moment where we see the inside of the
Red Face Demon's lair, and it's filled with marionettes.
Not only is this another example of a puppet, but within this movie it
symbolizes how the demon controls Dalton's body.
He's essentially moving him around like a puppet.
When Josh finds Dalton captive in the demon's lair, he's chained at the
ankles, which has got to be a callback to Saw.
Another item we've seen time and time again.
In Juan's work is mannequins.
They were used at the factory in Saw multiple times in Dead Silence, at
Parker's house in Insidious chapter two, and in the Amityville basement in
the Conjuring Two.
It's barely noticeable, but I did spot a mannequin in the Lambert's attic at
the first house in Insidious.
The door to the demonic layer in The Further is basked in red light.
This deep red color, in contrast to the blue hues of The Further, is
inspired by Giallo films.
Giallo is an Italian genre of mystery / thriller / horror stories, primarily in the
60s and 70s, which often portrayed a clash of red and blue neon light.
-[Leigh] We were inspired by filmmakers like Dario Argento, who take a very operatic approach.
-[James] Red and black are my color palettes that I love.
-[James] It really adds to the psychology of the film, and I really wanted the color
-[James] red to represent the evil in the movie.
James loves Giallo and has featured intense neon lights in many of his films,
primarily Dead Silence and Malignant.
The Further presented him with an opportunity to really exaggerate the Giallo lighting.
The metronome that Elise uses to hypnotize Josh also appears to be
an Italian product, so that may be a part of it.
Speaking of that scene, the phrases that she used to hypnotize him are taken
from the Chinese philosopher Laozi: the universe is deathless because having
no finite self, it stays infinite.
A sound man, by not advancing himself, stays the further ahead of himself,
by not confining himself to himself, sustains himself outside himself.
Originally, it seems the movie was going to open with this text because it
can be seen at the beginning of the script.
If you're a longtime fan of paranormal horror, you probably noticed a lot of
similarities to the 1982 classic Poltergeist.
Insidious is borderline a remake of this movie, a much more welcome one than
the actual remake.
They both open with the shot of the mom laying in bed.
They both feature a family of five with one of the young children getting
trapped in another plane of existence.
Both families call in a team of three paranormal investigators, but in
Poltergeist one of them quits and is replaced by an actual psychic, who is a
better equivalent of Elise.
In Poltergeist, the psychic explains that the other spirits are hungry for
the child's life force, whereas in Insidious, the psychic explains that the
spirits can smell his physical vessels available and want to possess him.
Both movies feature a scene where the family communicates with their child
and learns that there is a malicious entity after them.
Both movies have a climactic scene where one of the parents ventures into
the other world to rescue their kid.
In Poltergeist, one of the investigators sees a steak sliding across the
kitchen countertop all on its own, and perhaps as an homage, when Specs gets
injured after being Air Yeeted into the wall, he ices his head with a couple
of raw steaks, one of which sits directly on the kitchen counter.
When I was rewatching Poltergeist to make this video, I also noticed another
fun similarity between the two.
There's a crew member who actually worked on both movies, and it's the
cinematographer of Insidious, John Leonetti.
He was the first assistant to the camera operator for Poltergeist, which was
only the second major movie set he ever worked on.
As I mentioned, the evil entities in this franchise tend to take advantage
of the uncanny valley effect, which is when we get creeped out by something
that seems human but isn't quite human.
I think this also extends to other things that are not quite as they seem.
For example, the ghost boy that messes with Renai is actually a short man
dressed like a boy, and the bride in black is actually a man dressed as a woman.
The same can be said when we see this mysterious shadow near the
stairs during the opening credits, or when Josh runs up the stairs in the
middle of the night in daylight is momentarily pouring through the windows.
Okay, maybe that one's a mistake.
But the choice to make the Bride in Black, a man in woman's clothing is
expanded upon by giving the character a backstory in the sequel.
So join me in the next episode of Things You Missed, where I'll be covering
Insidious Chapter Two.
You'll find that video on the left.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every week.
Ring the death bell and select all notifications, and I'll see you in the
next one, assuming we both survive.